so yesterday after much media buildup
and extraordinary hype a small
collection of lgbt netflix employees and
their supporters rallied outside of
netflix headquarters in protest of a
comedy special a few dozen people showed
up with a ratio of about three reporters
to every one protester it was
reminiscent of a joe biden rally both in
terms of crowd size and demographic
netflix itself has over 12 000 employees
of those 12 000 maybe 12 participated in
the walkout and those 12 had significant
support
from not only the media but hollywood
various trans and trans affirming
celebrities released statements and
videos throwing their weight behind the
protesters eliot page
formerly ellen page the wachowski
sisters formerly the wachowski brothers
wanda sykes formerly wanda sykes all
along with many other celebrities to
voice their support for the netflix
employees who are offended because dave
chappelle said that women have vaginas
there were more
obscure supporters on the scene as well
the daily beast gives us this story uh
quote comedian seven graham who is
intersex trans mask non-binary and used
as he they pronouns was in attendance at
the protest telling the daily beast they
felt the special crossed a line quote i
actually found myself crying watching
this special because it says some very
difficult very painful very untrue
things about who trans people are graham
said this special will be used by people
to fuel that transphobia that has a very
real world effect for trans people as
soon as i heard that trans employees
were speaking out and amazing activists
like ashley marie preston were stepping
up and organizing this demonstration i
knew that i had to go
fellow protester nick bewick
uh agreed says i was angry for days and
i'm a fan of dave chappelle i've been a
fan since 2003 i've seen every single
one of his episodes i've seen every
single special sticks and stones kind of
touched upon a few things but it didn't
really bother me as bad
this seemed gratuitously aimed at us and
it wasn't funny it was gratuitously mean
it was gratuitously not funny it was
just self-glorification
self-masturbation i'm rich and famous
let me spew out all the things that i
think as if he was some sort of messiah
i think he got it twisted
so many people worship him and he's so
out of touch
yeah who do you think you are dave
chappelle giving your opinion like that
who do you think you are some some some
kind of messiah
you must have a messianic complex if you
would dare give your opinion
or tell jokes at a comedy special
see i'm trying as hard as i can to
picture
a professed comedian
sitting in his living room watching a
dave chappelle stand up special and
weeping
and i'm just having trouble conjuring
that image
we have to keep in mind that the the the
people in this assembly are shall we say
special and so for example just to put
an image with the lining let me play a
clip of one of the protesters explaining
why he or they or whatever
showed up on wednesday watch this yeah
my name is david huggard i'm a
non-binary individual i also go by the
persona of eureka o'hara which has been
debuted on rupaul's drag race uh season
9 10 all star six and hbo's we're here
and then eureka e-u-r-e-k-a-o-h-a-r-a
amazing so i mean i mean like why is it
so important to be out here today
yeah i know it's important to be out
here today because we have to stand in
solidarity with each other obviously uh
ashley marie preston is a a great
advocate and a huge sister of mine um
also a trans woman as a non-binary
person we as trans people and non-binary
people aren't getting visibility or
respect in the entertainment industry to
begin with and to have something like
dave chappelle special not be noted that
it's it's promoting discrimination and
hate conversation is very um hurtful to
the activism and the cause that we're
trying to progress ourselves in the
industry well it's good to see brian
stelter getting involved in the
community but remember
this is someone we're supposed to listen
to and take seriously eureka o'hara
deserves our attention and our respect
also remember they're not visible enough
even though 14 of them walked around
carrying signs for an hour and they made
it into the headlines of every major
news publication
but still not visible enough
and we need to make we need to make sure
we're not having hate conversations says
mr eureka
so we progressed past hate speech
and now it's hate conversation
some conversations themselves are
hateful to simply talk about certain
subjects is now an act of hate
that's what the activists are trying to
tell us
and it explains why they responded
violently to a quote counter protester
who showed up yesterday with a
provocative and offensive sign that said
we like dave and jokes are funny
that may seem like the most innocuous
and innocent statement ever written on a
sign in the whole history of signs
but that's not how the lgbt activists
viewed it let's see how they responded
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
now again remember the sign says we like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh do you want me to drop my weapon yes
okay
there's my weapon
i'm not distracting anything
i'm just here to say
that jokes are funny people
damn
funny guys
i love james
okay
so to recap he stood there peacefully
with a sign that said jokes are funny
they accosted him tore his sign apart
started shouting that he had a weapon
and uh which is a great thing to do
because there are cops all around and
they're shouting he has a weapon
i mean you know as far as they're
concerned they'd be fine getting the guy
killed they don't care
and that really is true by the way
they're shouting he's got a weapon
because he's holding the stick that the
sign was attached to that they just
destroyed and if a cop pulled out a gun
and just shot him there on the spot
they'd be happy
they really would be
and then they got in his face and they
tried to shove him you know out of the
protest but don't worry the media made
sure to report this incident fairly
here's variety
here's their headline
at times the netflix walkout situation
threatened to devolve as counter
protesters pushed against trans speakers
that's the media's framing doing
everything they can as always to earn
the enemy of the people moniker
that uh that trump gave them now
let's think about
the privilege on display here
the lgbt people at this protest
belong to the most pampered coddled
uh celebrated elevated
and disproportionately visible
demographic in america
some of them apparently also work for
netflix one of the richest and most
powerful corporations in the world
they live in silicon valley employed by
a fortune 500 company they are applauded
and worshipped just for existing they
are the very definition of privilege and
yet they pretend to be victimized over a
comedy special
one guy tells one joke they don't like
and it's a national emergency everybody
can bow before them lay palms before
their feet as they walk follow them
around cheering and fawning over them
and if one person just one says anything
mildly critical or makes a joke at their
expense they will collapse into a puddle
and demand an fbi investigation and
they'll get it
they'll get what they want because they
always do
and that's why the small size of the
protest
is not an embarrassment for them
i mean we can make fun of it we can
laugh it off
but they aren't ashamed
why should they be a shin the crowd
the crowd size
is is a symbol of power the crowd
displays its power by being small
think about it if you could go by
yourself and stand outside of a major
corporation's headquarters with a sign
demanding that they take some sort of
action at your behest and it worked
and you got what you wanted
would that image of you standing there
alone a crowd of one be embarrassing
no quite the opposite
we console ourselves with reassurances
that these people are in the minority
and they are
but they run everything and they get
exactly what they want every single time
and it's not so reassuring when you look
at it like that
so i hope you can see by now um and if
you listen to this show you must see it
because i'm hammering on the point all
the time but i hope you can see that
this stuff is not just about gender
or sexuality
it's certainly not about dave chappelle
what we're living through is a giant
social experiment that's the biggest
social experiment in world history
and what the experimenters are trying to
find out is this
can a vocal and powerful minority alter
the majority's perception of reality not
simply influence their opinions or
convince them to adopt a new position
but fundamentally change their very
perception of reality itself
primarily by screaming threatening and
cajoling them
can the human instinct
for self-preservation the natural desire
to avoid confrontation can these be
exploited to such an extent that
millions or billions of people can be
made to not only tacitly tolerate a
bizarre idea but to actually over time
believe it themselves
you know if they
in the minority
act like a statement a basic truth is
wildly offensive dangerous harmful it's
going to get people killed
if they do that
and they do it often enough can they not
only convince millions of people to keep
quiet but eventually can they convince
those timid masses to really believe
that the truth is offensive
and that it being offensive makes it
somehow not actually true
that's the experiment
we're all living through right now
those are the questions that the social
engineers are trying to answer and so
far
sad to say
the answer for many people has been yes
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated